thank you for your service so great
president Trump okay thank you so much
for all of your service as you know I'm
the commander in chief and so I promise
to ban trans and bring the military back
to what it used to be and that's a
promise
I've got your backs actually sir we're
all trans veterans what are you kidding
me you're trans veterans I am NOT a
trans veteran yeah there you go this guy
knows no it's all I know
no II don't sir I think there's some
things you don't understand I have no
military experience whatsoever which is
why I want to lecture you on why you're
wrong the American military has always
been filled with brave men then we added
women ugh and the gays and other trans
and it's all falling apart first job we
need to be in the trans because it's
costing so much money sir our defense
budget is seven hundred billion dollars
trans health care costs only between one
point four and four million dollars
annually further actually serving 15,000
estimated people but that's a lot of
money you know sir your viagra cost
eight times as much as it cost for the
healthcare for the transgender veterans
I don't yes ma'am who talks that what
are you talking about buddy anyway he's
saying
our enemies are at the gates North Korea
Iran the press nambia Narnia Mordor
they're all out to get us if you're
willing to switch your gender who says
you're not willing to switch sides sir
this is beyond the pale I did four
deployments with the Navy one with the
Coast Guard are you calling me a traitor
no I spent 17 years serving in the
military and earned a Purple Heart
through that time you think you're gonna
question my integrity for our country no
I did two combat tours to Iraq and one
to Afghanistan though we take an oath
that says we swear to protect and defend
the people of the United States sir stop
ganging up on me guys you get it right
no definitely don't get it sir I served
four years in the Marine Corps infantry
with a combat tour de Afghanistan I may
not be trans however I support the trans
veterans next to me and I definitely do
not support your ban on trans
servicemembers well I put myself in
harm's way so others don't have to I
chose to serve what didn't you serve I'm
serving now I'm the head of the military
I'm the toughest soldier I can run
around and I can fight the mud and grab
the rope why are they laughing about
them now wait a minute they're laughing
at me but I'm the top dog a big man
in the trenches welcome to hell you're
fake you got dirt in your muzzle
how you gonna fire that in combat this
is one of the gray wall
[Applause]
we're not gonna participate in this last
obstacle because your teammate here
obviously does not have what it takes
while these trans soldiers and sailors
and Marines have managed to just by man
it's embarrassing isn't it it's pretty
freaking embarrassing it are apparently
your marriage you can't do it
[Music]
the match up my butthole
it's not funny I got a mudbud alright
nothing I could do
[Music]